i was diving into this book yesterday
new york times best-selling author jeff
perlman joining us
three-ring circus kobe shack phil and
the crazy years of the laker dynasty
and uh jeff depicts what transpired
between 1996 and 19 or 2004
kobe and shaq combined collided and
helped bring the lakers to uh three
championships restoring the franchise
as a powerhouse and jeff joining us now
when did you uh start to approach this
project
uh about three years ago probably i had
finished a usfl book
and i was looking for a next sort of
project and i live in southern
california
and i just thought it's not that often
you get three iconic characters in one
subject so we have kobe shack and phil
it just struck me as a really sort of
good subject to tackle
biggest hurdle in trying to tackle this
i mean kobe wouldn't talk so when
obviously kobe was alive when i was
working on the book
and he was sort of you know i
the period includes eagle colorado
obviously which is a
pretty touchy subject and i was told
early on your your odds of getting kobe
bryant to talk
are not great and uh that was correct so
that that was probably the biggest
hurdle
and uh tell me the number i think it was
close to 300 people
interviewed for this book is it about
300 306 i think maybe
yeah best interview you had out of the
300
oh well there were two um phil jackson
gave me
so um jeannie bus arranged the interview
and
i thought i was getting an hour and when
i flew out to montana to meet him
he greeted me and he said i said thanks
coach for doing this and he said i'm not
doing it for you i'm doing it
and then he goes let's drive around the
lake so
it was a three-hour drive around i think
flathead lake it's called
then we stopped for lunch then he's like
you want to go back to my house and go
back to my house go back to his house
we're sitting on the porch
at one point we're sitting on the porch
on rocking chairs and um
his chair goes over a cat and the cat's
just gonna find
like the efforts all over and and then
he's like i'm gonna take a nap so
you wanna get dinner later i was like
yeah great it was
it was i basically won the eight hour
like spend your day with phil jackson
in montana tour you know raffle prize
it was great and then um j.r ryder was
on the 2000 2001 lakers
remember jr hell yeah isaiah isaiah
yeah and um i didn't have a phone number
for him
so i only had an address i was going to
be in arizona
so i figured i would drive i have a
decent track record of knocking on doors
so i drove out to j.r rider's house and
uh
it was one of my most memorable moments
in my career i knock on the door and a
kid answers
and i'm like hey i'm looking for jr
rider it's like hold on
a woman comes the door hey i'm looking
for j.r ryder my name is jeff from a
reporter
hold on the door closes and i hear two
people yelling in the background
like who what who is this j.r ryder
comes the door
who that for you hey my name's jeff
roman i'm a writer
he goes no no man
no no you just you show up
you show up bro that's not bro i don't
think so man bro
no then he opens the door and comes out
and he's like
bro i'm saying man that is not cool you
do not just ride up on someone's house
what's this book you're working on it's
about the lakers
he's like all right i'll talk to you wow
you really had to work in there to get
him to open up charm and good looks
uh how was shaq zach was great i got uh
an hour and about 20 minutes with shaq
and atlanta
he was fanta couldn't have been better
and i'll tell you a quick shack story
that i just loved
is um i was interviewing him and in the
middle of the interview
his cell phone rings he goes excuse me
he picks his cell phone and he's on
facetime and he's
clearly none of this he doesn't care
that i'm there as far as his regards but
it's his daughter
his daughter says something like uh hey
daddy i just wanted you to know that
so and so i think it was a mother of a
friend of hers
died and she said you know i just wanted
to know that so-and-so's mom died
it's really sad and shack goes to her he
goes i will never forget this he goes
listen i'm paying for the funeral make
sure they know they don't have to pay
for a single thing i'm taking care of
all the expenses
just make sure they know i'm paying for
it all okay all right daddy thanks i
love you you're the best click buy
so what were you talking about is one of
the nicest
three second moments i've ever witnessed
in my life
what do we clear up in this book jeff
i mean i feel like i do
kind of get to the root of the
relationship i think
it is awkward obviously the book was
written all completely before kobe
bryant's
passing so it's kind of awkward to talk
about some of it
i do think the root of the shakobe
troubles
kind of go on kobe bryant um i think he
iraq you know he arrived for his first
meeting his first team meeting in 1996.
in hawaii everyone's gathered around
dale harris as a coach
all right everyone let's just do quick
introductions all right hey i'm nick van
exel from cincinnati hey i'm eddie jones
yo my name's kobe bryant lower marion
nobody here is gonna punk me
like that was his sort of hey i'm kobe
ryan
and players are you know guys are like
yeah that did not go over well
and shaq really wanted through the years
this relationship
he wanted you know he talked about it
the batman robin the big brother little
brother
and kobe didn't want that at all like
didn't want that at all
when kobe got married to his wife
vanessa in dana point
zero teammates were invited most of
teammates didn't know the wedding was
happening
most of the teammates didn't know he was
even dating someone
his throughout his career veterans were
brought in one after another afternoon
like j.r reid told me a great sir jerry
reid was acquired in the glen rice trade
from charlotte
and jerry west loved j.r reid he said i
really love the way you work with young
players can you help
can you bring kobe more into the team
j.r reeve's like i'm on it i got it
they're on the plane yo kobe when you
come back here play cards with us nah
i'm good
yo kobe we're all going out to eat five
of us are going out d why don't you come
with us
nah i'm good yo kobe we're all going to
a movie wanna go see a movie no i'm good
he actually went back to jerry west and
said
there's nothing i can do here and i just
think that relationship truly was a guy
shaquille o'neal
who wanted a bond and wanted to be this
guy to this other guy
and another guy and it's not a criticism
of him because it's just who he was
kobe bryant just didn't want that like
he had no need for it he didn't see it
as anything he
required when he was going through the
sexual assault situation in 2003
he reports a training camp first day
he's late and he's surrounded by
reporters and someone says
um are you gonna turn to your teammates
for support during this time and his
reaction his
actual response was why would i do that
like he just
was not a person who sought that or
needed it and it drove a real wedge i
think between the two of them
in many ways i remember being in dallas
and the lakers were in town they were
going to play the mavs
and i think it was the night before and
shaq rick fox a couple other players
were out
and i approached rick fox and then i
said um
hey where's kobe and he goes he
he and then he goes shot come here come
come here
and he goes he wants to know where kobe
is and and chad goes
he don't come out he don't come out and
then they started laughing like it was
the craziest thing that i'd ever ask
that where's
where's kobe and they said he stays in
his room all the time
wait i'll tell you two quickies um john
sally was with the
lakers for one year phil jackson's first
year
and he told me one night he got kobe to
come out in south beach and he it was a
huge win for john sally getting kobe
bryant to come out at south beach
and um they're at a club it's 10 30.
john sally is on top of the world
because he got kobe to come out
kobe looks at his watch and he's like uh
yeah man
i got to go and john sally's like you
got 10 30. what are you talking about
he's like yeah i got to work out at five
tomorrow morning i can't
i gotta go and then when i was with shaq
one thing he said to me that i just
thought was really kind of telling and
interesting
i said to him it was my last question i
asked him i was like uh
you know you always gave yourself
nicknames but it was it was jovio
there was always with a wink you know it
was always like shaktis on the big
aristotle but it's never serious it
wasn't like he was really calling
himself that
and i said and shat and kobe nicknamed
himself black mama
but he seemed like he literally sort of
viewed himself as the black mamba like
it was a thing to him
and shot kind of he smiled and he goes
now you know what i was dealing with bro
he's jeff pearlman the book is three
ring circus kobe shack
phil the crazy years of the laker
dynasty
i love the uh draft day story with uh
the nets and john calipari
and i read it and i was cringing that
here's calipari
trying to do something in new jersey and
he's got a chance to draft kobe
pick up the story from there well the
nets are going to do it they have the
eighth pick in the draft
john nash is the general manager
calipari is a first-year coach
and here's kobe bryant and he's a
regional star that's the other thing
lower marion not that far away from from
east rutherford
so they have decided they've worked out
kobe four or five times
they love him the one thing they did
they actually it's funny they screwed up
something
they had to fly kobe from his workout in
new jersey to la
and they put him in a middle seat on a
delta flight
for the flight and uh his agents were
not happy about that
but they still they love kobe bryant and
they work him out and the day before the
draft they call pam and joe kobe's
parents
and they say um how do you feel about us
drafting your son because kobe was only
17 at the time so they actually had to
say to the parents
parents like yeah it's great but we'd
love that he's close by
right so kobe has a sneaker deal with
adidas worked out with sonny vacara
that's done
and adidas does not want kobe bryant
playing east rutherford
for the freaking khalid reed and ed
o'bannon they just don't want that
and jerry and artem uh kobe's agent are
close
and jerry west works out kobe ryan twice
it's the two best workouts he's ever
seen anyone give
ever he decimated dante jones and then
he decimated michael cooper
in back-to-back workouts and he wants
kobe bryant
so they kind of everything is working
behind the scenes here he wants
they want kobe d doesn't want kobe the
day before the draft
kobe calls john calipari and says um
yeah coach i've been thinking about it
and i don't want to uh i don't really
want to play near my parents i don't
want to be near my parents i kind of
want to get away
so i don't really want you guys to draft
me well cow he's like in his mid-30s
this is his first draft you know he's a
little high energy
he goes to john nationally he's like oh
my god what are we going to do this is
he doesn't want play brass and john nash
is like
calm down i'll just deploy don't worry
about it
then kobe's aging calls john calipari
he's like listen don't draft kobe do
draft kobe he's probably gonna either
play in italy for the year or sit out
he's not gonna play for you
calipari to john nash oh my god what are
we gonna do this is the worst thing ever
the best moment happens um carrie
kittles of villanova all-american good
player
is represented by david flock david fox
calls
john calipari and says you know cal
carrie really wants to play for the nets
he wants to stay regional
if you don't draft him i cannot promise
you that i will be having players free
free agents calipari is like
holy crap what the hell again john what
are we going to do
calm down that's the thing so john nash
is convinced the night before the draft
we're it's okay
we're going to take kobe bryant this is
going to be a generational player for
our franchise
the next day calipari holds a meeting
and the one thing in cal's contract he
had final personnel say
over his general manager what's this
meeting john nash is there
and he goes uh all right guys here's
what we're gonna do carrick
carrie kittles is on the board at number
eight we're going with kerry kittles if
not
we're taking kobe bryant and john nash
is absolutely devastated
and as soon as the nets announcer david
stern announces the nets have selected
kerry kendall's guard villanova
jerry west knows what the next four
kicks are none of them have shown an
interest in kobe ryan
and when they drop when charlotte picks
brian and they make the swap for vladi
divac
jerry west goes into jerry buss's office
and says i just got you the best player
in this draft
oh poor cow poor cow
if i gave you one basketball question
for kobe what would it have been
oh man i mean the thing i'm fascinated
with him
truly is he
he arrived and this is to his credit 1
million
he arrived knowing he was going to be
the next michael jordan
like it wasn't a doubt for him it was
zero to
he arrived knowing he was better than
eddie jones and should be starting and
he resented dale harris for not letting
him start
he arrived knowing there should be post
when dall harris was a coach
kobe goes from as a rookie and says
coach why don't you have more post up
plays for me down low
dow harris's response is because we have
shaquille o'neal like
the confidence the one thing i feel like
i don't fully understand about kobe ryan
and i would love to
i wish i had the opportunity was um
where does
that level of self-assuredness and
wherewithal and like he didn't care what
his
teammates thought about him to his
credit he didn't
care whatever they were saying about him
he didn't care i think one of the things
that bothered him about shaq
is shaq was sort of sitting in judgment
of him and he actually didn't
he didn't care like he was like off his
shoulder you know he didn't care
and i just i wish i had that i'm sure
most people wish they had that
he had that ability where he was just
deaf do it all i'm here to play
basketball i would love to understand
that better than i do
so it didn't bother him what people
thought of him
but he would sit in judgment of others
well i think what bothered him there
were things about
just as an example there were things
about shaq that really bothered him
um the free throw thing killed him just
killed him he
i asked i talked to derek harper former
laker long time nba guy and i was like
about shaq and free throws and he was
very blunt about it he said i will give
you the secret to why
shaq wasn't good at free throws i was
waiting for this big answer and he goes
because he didn't work at it he's like
he just didn't work at it like he didn't
work hard enough at it
that crap drove kobe crazy he did not
understand how you could not hit
70 of your free throws and why you
wouldn't work hard at it
so he definitely sat in judgment of shaq
with that
he definitely felt shaq didn't work hard
enough i don't know if i necessarily
agree with that but he didn't he didn't
really work hard enough
so it was the basketball things that
bothered him but was it you know was he
sitting in judgment that shaq was off
making you know mediocre movies
or doing this or doing that no he just
how does this affect me
yeah and you not shooting free throws
affects me directly
good luck with the book fascinating read
uh
it uh well researched as always with you
and
uh at times it was painful to read some
of the things about kobe uh
a three-ring circus kobe shack phil in
the crazy years of the laker dynasty
uh jeff thanks for joining us we
appreciate it all right thanks dan
jeff perlman